真正讓你進步的 不是你寫了多少文章 派了多少的視頻
真正讓你進步的是你改了多少次
今天給大家分享一套特備簡單 簡單到另外發尺的這麼一套系統
其實這兩步 只要你做了 真對體會的你做了
你的人生真的會發生改變
太簡單了 了吧 而且你會發現我說的東西 你好像都知道
你沒有會發現我拍攝被總是重褲的
這個差別所在 我還能會找到一個特備有用的東西
然後反覆掉 反覆修改 反覆重褲的
我們大部分的問題 不斷的學習的東西 沒有幾個能用出來的
不說廢話了 最大性的做兩點 第一點就是每天寫下什麼
很熟吧 第二個是每天帶點什麼 終點在後面這個
先說每天寫下什麼 我們大多數的問題有什麼呢 就是滿滿主意
好像一上來就寫的特備好 結果半天不動 所以最好的方法是什麼
將第一 阻離 比如說你想跑步 最好的方法是什麼
就是動吧 直接去樓下 穿上寫出樓下 穿上寫到樓下
你為了寫東西 怎麼辦 先打開電腦 打開電腦 打開電腦 先敲兩個字 就是這麼簡單
所以每天寫帶什麼 就是不要求寫的多 好 你可以像一圖高水一樣
對吧 可能就說一句話 十幾個字上就把一個想法都可以 把他寫了 就可以每天就養成這樣一個動作
就是高水也不要寫 每天的養成的每個動作 養成這麼一個習慣 習慣
大家都知道沒在寫什麼 但是系統的一部分 中年在第2個部分 就每天帶點什麼
第2天 把你昨天的內容拿著再看 以後發現不一樣了
為什麼呢 因為你第二天在看的時候 你變成了一個觀眾 你昨天寫的時候的創作者 作為觀眾的時候你會發現這裏沒有那些問題
切換角度了 對不對 然後你會發現問題 注意這個時候就說改了 發現問題你要改的
改的時候也不要想的意思 把它改做好 每天改掉 可能就是篩一段話 篩幾個恩阿的字 中年加一個連接 這個地方簡單 一部分人色 替換兩句話 就可以了
就是改進一點點 就不舒服就改進一點點
那 這個問題在哪 主要這句話很重要 問題加修改 這樣就進步 系也是輸出告 才是進步
所以在改的公共就是發現問題 到找到一種解決法 恩來和他進一批
所以總是發現問題 解決問題 解決問題 解決問題的 解決問題的那個技能就是不斷的升級不斷的更新 不斷的屁肯來好一點點
這道系動還有一個特別大的好處是什麼呢 方崩潰行動 組我們好的人就實際開這條小完美 這條小完美 這條小完美 這條小完美 一向要寫個一千字 三千字的
這是寫了也不好 比較寫得不好 寫得不好 忘了一塊一堆 而又不忍職事 所以的篩文章可能就廢了
但是我們因為以前寫成不去的 一小段 不斷的乾淨曾經也成果的 乾淨成就成果的 恩 沒斷的啊 都會很精美的
當然 改過了改的過程了 這也是因為真正的重要的點在哪 各位 就是福利的 你看你 今天寫點什麼 明天改了什麼
這麼一個動作好像沒什麼 但是如果你把這個鮮拉長 可能一年三百六十五天 每天改了什麼
那麼 每天改了什麼東西 就是不斷的釣用一的問題 解決問題就算 然後技能提升 今天寫 這麼改 更好一點 明天寫 這麼改 更好一點
所以你會發現一年下來 你的對 一段內容啊 你改了一邊兩邊三邊四邊
對吧 你不斷的重構 然後你會變成一個作品 所以有一段話我會把它變成一天文章
一條偷有別好的視頻 或者是一本書 或者是一個抓納 你的一條鍋是變成了產品 對吧
第二個部分的話 就是你在寫的公眾 這個地方 這麼寫 這麼寫 這麼寫 每天有一點點技能的提升
拍什麼樣的樣 每天有一點點技能的提升 就好多人為什麼 拍了好多條是 因為每天都在重複做些的自己
一點一點一點 一點點進步 預言下來 你的拍攝短視頻的能力啊 你寫作的能力一定會有提升的
最重要的後面是什麼 就是你思考 寫作我氣思考 問題解放他們的你的系統在什麼機
所以你看 看著好像就是每天寫在什麼 每天帶在什麼 但它實際上是一個能夠讓你不斷產生產品的
不斷的提升你進能的 不斷讓你能夠自我別帶升級的操作系統